JEFFREY POSNICK: So, Yaniv,
have we started yet?
YANIV INBAR: Not yet.
You know, it's been such an
exciting day, so much
incredible information, I would
just like to take a
moment to meditate first.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, OK,
but have we started yet?
YANIV INBAR: Not quite yet.
I really appreciate the
enthusiasm, but I'd just like
a moment to meditate first.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
How about now?
Have we started yet?
YANIV INBAR: Not quite yet.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
How about now?
YANIV INBAR: Yeah,
let's do it.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
YANIV INBAR: Let's
get started.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Awesome.
So I'm Jeff Posnick.
I'm a member of the Developer
Relations Team working on the
YouTube API.
YANIV INBAR: And I'm
Yaniv Inbar.
I'm a technical lead
in the Google API
Infrastructure Team.
JEFFREY POSNICK: And today
we're going to be talking
about YouTube API push
notifications.
And people might be familiar
with the fact that asking the
same question over and over
again is annoying, whether
it's two presenters on stage
or whether it's your web
application talking
to Google servers.
So I'm sure tons of people have
written code that pretty
much does this.
Anything new?
YANIV INBAR: No.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Anything new?
YANIV INBAR: Yes.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Awesome.
But anything new?
YANIV INBAR: No.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
So this is the polling paradigm
of writing code where
your web application's trying
to figure out whether
something's happened either in
the YouTube world or any of
the other Google
APIs out there.
And polling is bad.
We want people to say no to
polling and change their way
of writing applications.
One of the problems with polling
is it's really hard to
find the right interval
to poll.
You could say, let's poll every
hour, where we ask the
server whether anything's new.
And there are problems
with that.
You might receive your
events late.
It could be up to 59 minutes in
between the time something
happens and when you find out
about it, about 30 minutes on
average for any event.
So you really don't have
instant feedback.
And you may miss events.
If you have a really long poll
interval, there could be like
three different things that
happened to a resource in
between that interval.
And maybe the final stage state
didn't change, so you
can't really detect it once you
do get around to polling.
So you're losing some
data there.
So the next reaction that people
have is, OK, well,
let's poll every minute.
Let's poll at the other
end of the spectrum.
And that's not great.
You end up wasting network
bandwidth.
And in that case,
you're sending a
lot of extra requests.
You might actually also
run into quota issues.
As we're well aware, many of
Google's APIs and YouTube APIs
are also in that category,
have quota
associated with them.
And you want to make your
API calls count.
So you don't want to just have
calls that are asking the same
thing and getting back the no
response again and again.
So what can people do instead?
And we're happy to say you
can now say yes to push
notifications.
And the whole model behind push
notifications is that
instead of my web application
asking Google whether
something's changed,
Google says, hey.
YANIV INBAR: Guess what?
I've got something new
for you, Jeff.
JEFFREY POSNICK: And that's very
nice of Google to tell me
when something is new.
Because Google and the
YouTube APIs, we know
when things have happened.
So we can tell interested
parties,
hey, something's changed.
Benefits, hopefully,
are obvious.
You have lower network bandwidth
that's used, lower
quota consumption, almost
immediate notifications when
something's changed.
So it's a much better user
experience overall.
And, I mean, honestly, it's
a much better developer
experience.
Nobody really likes writing
while loops that are just
running in the background.
So we have a much nicer
experience overall.
And I'm going to hand things
over to Yaniv to talk about
the life of a notification
channel.
YANIV INBAR: That's a really
great explanation of the
problem that we tried
to solve.
So I'm on the Google API
Infrastructure Team.
And we built a protocol, which
we're calling notification
channels, not to be confused
with, say, YouTube channels.
It's a totally different
thing.
And I'll talk in detail about
how the protocol works, give
you a good conceptual overview
of the life of a
notification channel.
And what I'll be talking
about today is webhook
notifications.
This is a common technique
that's
actually used on the web.
You'll see where a website
registers an endpoint where
they can receive callbacks.
And we're going to be using
webhook to register your
application's notification
endpoint where you'll be
receiving callbacks every time
something's changed.
So let's take a look.
The first thing you do whenever
using YouTube API, if
you've ever built a web
application that uses the
YouTube API, is you have to
register your application.
And if you've ever done that,
you might be familiar with
this already.
We've renamed it the Google
Cloud Console.
And this is a new URL.
And the first thing you do
is you want to enable the
YouTube Data API.
You want to accept the
terms of service.
You'll want to register your
application, give the name of
your application, set up the
consent screen that is shown
to your users, as well as define
what platform your
application is running on.
In this case, it's going to be a
web application, but we also
support mobile applications or
native applications that are
installed on desktop devices.
And, finally, and the reason
why I showed you--
went into details here is that
we're soon going to enable a
requirement that you register
the domain where you're going
to be receiving notification
endpoints.
The reason we do that is we
want to make sure that you
actually own that domain.
If you're running on one of
Google's cloud platforms, say,
an App Engine or Compute
Engine, we already know
whether you own that domain.
But if it's another domain,
you'll lead to register your
endpoint domain.
So I'm going to be talking about
OAuth 2 here because
it's central to using the
YouTube API whenever you're
making requests.
And there are a variety
of different flows
that OAuth 2 supports.
And it's a standard protocol
on the web.
This literally is now
a final standard.
So you'll see a lot of different
sources use it.
And I'll demonstrate here one
type of flow, which is where a
user owns the data.
And the key thing about OAuth 2
is that it is intended for a
client application to access
protected resources.
So how does Google know
that it's OK to
access the user's data?
Well, we start here.
That's a picture of me.
That's supposed to
be the user.
And I think that picture needs
a little bit of enhancement,
maybe take out some
of the wrinkles.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Skin glow.
YANIV INBAR: All right.
So what happens when the user
goes to your web app?
Well, you go to the web app,
says I'd like to use your
application.
So the web goes to Google and
says, is it OK to start--
please start the authorization
process.
So Google asks the user, is it
OK to grant access to this web
application?
And when the user grants
access, you
get an access token.
And this is really key, because
any time you're going
to be accessing the
use-protected resources,
you'll want to use that
access token.
And I'll show you how
that works in detail
a little bit later.
And in this case, because this
is a sample of how a
notification channel works, the
web app is going to ask
the user which collection the
user would like that web app
to listen for.
So I'm using the word
collection.
It might sound a little
bit abstract.
Think of a YouTube playlist.
That's a good example
of a collection.
But the reason I chose the word
collection and not just a
YouTube playlist is because we
built this is as a protocol.
And you'll be able to use the
exact same protocol, say, with
Google Cloud Storage API.
We just recently announced
that they support push
notifications.
And maybe there'll be other
Google APIs that support push
notifications in the future.
So you'll be able to refer to
this presentation in the
future as well.
So let's take a look at the
start of watching for changes
on that collection.
The web app makes a
request to Google.
It's calling the items.watch
request.
And Jeff will later show you an
example of how to use our
client libraries to make
this really simple.
And Google will say, OK.
It's all right.
We started that notification
channel.
And you can see there's all
the collection there that
we're going to reference when
we call items.watch.
And it's owned by the user.
There's two items in
there already.
And, at the same time, the
notifications endpoint, which
is running that same domain that
you registered earlier,
will receive what's called
a sync notification.
This is an opportunity for the
notifications endpoint to then
go to Google and say, give me
the current state of that
collection.
So whenever I receive
notifications in the future,
I'll know what's changed.
I'll be able to figure
that out.
So think of this as a chance
to synchronize your web
application with Google.
And when you're done with that,
just return a 200 OK.
Everything went fine.
Now, let's go into more detail
what just happened here.
When you make the items.watch
request, you have to specify a
few things to Google.
The first is a collection ID.
This is an identifier that
specifies exactly what
collection you're
listening to.
Think of this as the
playlist ID.
The second piece of information
is that access token.
As I mentioned earlier, at the
end of the OAuth 2 flow,
you'll get an access token.
That's what you'll use in the
authorization header.
The third piece of information
is the
notification endpoint address.
That's a URL where you're going
to be receiving your
notification running on one
of the domains that you
registered with your
application.
And, finally, there's the
universally unique identifier
of the notification channel.
This is unique for your
web application.
And your application is the one
that has to specify it in
order to make sure that
whenever you receive a
notification, you'll be able
to know exactly which
notification channel it's
receiving a notification for.
So perhaps you have
a lot of users.
You'll want to know exactly
which user this notification
is associated with, and also
which collection it's
associate with.
And maybe multiple users are
sharing the same collection.
So you really need something
that's unique.
The good news is that most
programming languages provide
a very simple way to
get a random UUID.
And Jeff will show you
an example of that
a little bit later.
Finally, there is
a channel token.
This is for your needs.
It's optional.
You don't have to specify it.
It's just to make it much easier
for you to process the
notification.
It's going to be something
that's custom for your
application.
Maybe it helps the application
know how to process the
notification.
Maybe it helps identify
what user this is.
There's a variety of things
you can use it for.
But it's available to you.
So this is what the
HTTP looks like.
Now, if you're using one of
our client libraries, you
don't really need to know
the HTTP protocol.
But I still think it's useful
for you to understand, just
conceptually, what's going on.
You're making a post request
to a specific URL.
It'll probably end
with /watch.
And you're specifying
the Playlist
ID and query parameter.
The authorization header
is where you
put that access token.
Again, to access the user's
protect data, you've got to
specify the access token.
And because it's a post, there's
a JSON body here.
And you specify a few things.
One is that we're using
webhook and the
notification URL.
In this case it's /notifications
on my website.
And I want to you to
notice is HTTPS.
That's actually important.
We want to make sure that these
requests are made to a
secure location.
The ID, that's that
unique identifier
that's a channel ID.
And, finally, there's
a custom token.
You could leave that out.
It's your choice.
Now, the watch response
from Google will
typically be a 200 OK.
Everything went fine,
assuming the
authorization check worked.
And it'll give you a bunch
of information.
The key information that I
want to highlight for you
today is that expiration time.
Now, this varies between
different Google APIs.
You'll want to read their
documentation to
learn how it works.
It is possible to
set an infinite
channel expiration time.
But, typically, it's a one-hour
expiration time.
That's what YouTube
has implemented.
And it'll come back to you.
Here is what the HTTP
response looks like.
Some of this information, such
as the ID, is just giving you
back what you sent Google.
And there's some things like
the resource ID and the
resource URI, which I just
don't have time to
go into right now.
But they might be
of use to you.
But most important here is
that expiration time.
This is the number of
milliseconds of Unix time.
So you can look at that, too.
And you maybe want to store that
information, for example.
I'll talk a little more about
the end of notification
channels a little bit later.
So let's take a look at
the sync notification.
This is what we built
this for.
We want to receive a
notification the moment that
you set up a notification
channel.
You'll get a couple pieces
of information.
The resource state
here is sync.
I'll show you the two other
possible resource states in
just a moment.
There is that unique
identifier.
Again, that's helping you
identify exactly which
notifications this is
associated with.
And that optional channel token
that might help you
process the notification.
So here is what the HTTP
request looks like.
Again, this is Google calling
your web application
notification endpoint.
Most of the information
is in those headers.
So one piece of information
is the resource state.
In this case, it's sync.
There's a channel ID and channel
token that I mentioned
earlier, as well also some
of the other pieces of
information.
And there's also a message
number, which I won't have
time to go into, but is
sometimes useful, especially
in error cases.
And a successful notification
response from your
notification endpoint is just
going to be 200 OK.
There's really nothing
more to it.
I'll mention one neat trick
that you can use
a little bit later.
But here's the HTTP.
Very simple, you don't really
need to give Google anything,
just 200 OK.
Make sure it's 200 and
not something else.
And I'll tell you
why in a moment.
So here's a typical app scenario
where the users uses
some client application, maybe
it's on their mobile device,
maybe it's somewhere else.
That's not really important.
My point is it doesn't need to
be your web application.
It could be from anywhere.
It's going to be making some
change to the collection.
It's going to be inserting
a new item.
It's going to call the
items.insert method.
And you can see that little
animation, that new item,
popping up in your collection.
And Google is going to
then notify your
notifications endpoint.
The only thing that's different
between a sync
notification and this scenario
is that the resource state
will be exists.
And, again, it returns
a 200 OK.
So here's a little bit more
detail about the exists
notification.
The resource state is exists.
I mentioned that earlier.
The channel ID, channel token,
HTTP looks almost the same.
The only thing that's really
changed here, other than the
message number, which increases
every time, is the
resource state.
Now, you might be thinking,
what do I do if
I receive an exists?
Is there any more information
about
exactly what just happened?
I'm just displaying the
basic protocol.
APIs have the option to give
more information, such as the
JSON metadata about that new
item that was inserted.
It might be a URL where you
can get more information.
In the case of YouTube, there
won't be such a JSON payload,
but it's useful to know, for
example, Google Cloud Storage
API has chosen to use it.
So here is a case where you've
got an update going on.
And it's a very simple
scenario.
The client application is
calling items.update.
And the item got updated.
And Google is going to send
an exists notification,
just like an insert.
OK.
So the information
is the same.
Message number increased.
The resource state is exists.
So you might be thinking, how
do I tell between an update
and an insert?
Well, we don't really have a way
to give you a difference.
Again, that's going to be
specific to the scenario that
you're talking about.
So Jeff will show an example of
how he manages that in his
demo just a little bit later.
Now, what happens when
you delete an item?
It's very similar
to an update.
The item will now fly away.
And Google will send a
notification to the
notification endpoint
not.exists is
the resource state.
So those are the three
possible states--
a sync, which is sent exactly
once at the beginning of a
notification channel; an exists,
whenever an item got
inserted or updated; or
not.exists, when it got deleted.
And here's some more
details about it.
Again, the resource state is
not.exists, and channel ID,
channel token, and HTTP
protocol, just showing you
everything's pretty similar
except the resource state is
not.exists and the message
number increased again.
So what do we do if the server
is not reachable?
This happens sometimes.
Maybe the server is down.
Maybe there is some
kind of problem.
Who knows what could go wrong?
We'll give you some assurance
that we'll make an attempt to
still send that notification
to you.
So if, say, it's a 503,
some server error.
Google will wait a little bit of
time and then send you that
notification again.
If it's still an error, it'll
retry that notification up
until some threshold.
I don't remember exactly
what it is.
Maybe it's 75 minutes.
But whatever that threshold is,
it will make an attempt
until it receives
an OK response.
Now, that message number might
be useful, because that
message number will be the same
every time it retries the
notification.
So you'll be able to catch the
case where there's duplicates.
So, finally, in the life of a
notification channel, how do
we stop it?
Well, one possibility is the
notification channel might
expire within an hour.
Another possibility, if you
actually want to manually stop
notifications--
perhaps the user is no longer
using your application--
one way to do that is in your
notification endpoint, you
still return a 200 OK, but you
can add an additional header
to tell it to stop.
And this is what the HTTP
protocol looks like.
X-Goog-Channel with
a value of stop.
And Google simply stops sending
notifications for that
one specific notification
channel for that one user with
that one collection.
It doesn't mean stop all
notifications, period--
just that one channel.
Now, the other option is, if
you're not in the notification
endpoint, you can also simply
call the channels.stop method,
where you have to specify
exactly what is, again, that
access token that you used
earlier, as well as that
channel ID to specify exactly
which channel you want to stop
receiving notifications from.
That's pretty much it
for the protocol.
You will be able to get a
lot more details in the
documentation that
we'll post later.
And this is what the HTTP
request looks like when you
stop a channel.
And you just have to specify
the channel ID.
But I'll have hand it off at
this point to Jeff to show you
what this looks like
in practice.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
Thanks, Yaniv.
So we have a great
infrastructure to
build on top of.
And I'm sure everybody out there
has ideas for how they
might want to use this.
I want to demonstrate a sample
application that I put together.
This is going to be a Chrome
extension that allows you to
subscribe to a specific playlist
and get notified when
new videos are added to
that YouTube playlist.
Just a little caveat, we don't
have the code available right
now for folks to use, but we'll
release it shortly.
So let's pull that up, and I'm
going to walk you through the
entire flow of using it from
loading the local extension.
Over here, we have our YouTube
playlist notifier.
Unfortunately, it's a little
small over here in the corner
of the screen.
But the first thing that we
need to do is we have this
little question mark
over here.
And it just doesn't know which
playlist we want to listen to.
So let's create a
new playlist.
I'm going to use the Google
API's Explorer to do that.
And I have everything already
pre-populated.
And I'm going to click
Execute down here.
And this is going to use the
YouTube API to create a new
playlist for me.
So that's great.
I have my JSON resource
says returned.
And the thing I care about is
the ID of that new playlist.
I'm going to copy it, go back
to my application, and I can
now paste that in
and click Save.
And, at this point, what I get
presented with is this screen
asking me for permission.
So this is actually
the OAuth 2 flow
that's built into Chrome.
This is actually quite neat.
If you're doing JavaScript
development, if you're running
Chrome extensions, it makes it
really easy to get OAuth 2
tokens for the currently
logged-in user to Chrome.
And it's just saying it wants
to view my YouTube account.
I'm going to click Allow.
After I go through that, it's
going to establish the
connection.
And behind the scenes it's
doing the watch.
We're going to dive into the
code in a little bit, but I
just wanted to show off what
this could actually do.
I'm going to now add a video to
the playlist I'm watching.
So I have, again, the
API Explorer up.
Most of these fields are already
there, but let me put
in the new playlist ID.
And before I click Execute, just
take a look in the upper
right-hand corner
of the screen.
That's where, hopefully,
the magic will happen.
Click Execute and we have
over here, right now
it's switched to one.
So there is now one video that's
available to watch.
And if I click over here, you
can see the new videos that
are in the playlist, a shameless
plug for my I/O talk
from last year.
Everybody, I'm sure, wants to
watch that and be notified
right away when that's
added to a playlist.
So this happened, everything
behind the scenes, more or
less in real time.
And I want to dive in to how
we actually built that.
So a number of different
components that went into this
application.
We have the user-facing client,
which is Chrome and
Chrome Extension.
There is some middleware,
which is the App Engine
instance I have running, and
that's what's going to take
care of receiving notifications
and doing some
the API calls for us.
And, obviously, we have
the YouTube API.
This wouldn't be a YouTube talk
without the YouTube API
factoring in somewhere.
So first things going on, where
we went through the
OAuth 2 flow.
We have a access token
for the current user.
And I'm going to, in my Chrome
Extension, make a call to my
App Engine in instance saying,
hey, I want you
to kick off a watch.
I'm going to pass in
my OAuth 2 token.
I'm going to also pass in the
playlist ID that I want to
start watching.
And the App Engine instance
will make a call to the
YouTube API on my behalf.
It'll call the
playlistItems.watch method.
I'm actually going to be
using the Python client
library to do that.
And we'll show you the real
code in a second.
And, at that point, once I get
a successful response, and
once my push notification
subscription is active, I'm
going to open up a channel
connection to Chrome from my
App Engine.
So this is using the App
Engine channel's API.
And this provides a really easy
way for App Engine to
push things down to Chrome
and to notify me when
there's a new video.
So that's the watch flow.
And let's go through the actual
Python code that was
used to create that
watch flow.
Again, Python client library
makes this real easy.
It's just a question, once you
have your YouTube object and
it's already authenticated and
all that, you call the watch
method, passing the
playlist ID, you
pass in particle snippet.
This is just your way of telling
YouTube that you care
about general metadata about
the new video that's been
added to the playlist.
And there's a body.
And this corresponds directly
to the body of the post
request that Yaniv went
over earlier.
So this shouldn't be a surprise
to anybody who saw
the earlier portion
of the code.
The two things I
wanted to note.
I am making use of that optional
channel token that
Yaniv mentioned.
And I'm, in this case, passing
in the playlist ID as a
channel token.
The purpose is writing
application, I found it easier
to use that value to store
that state about which
playlist I'm going
to be watching.
And that'll make it easier
to get the state of the
collection later on when
I get notifications.
The other thing I wanted to
point out is that unique UUID.
To generate that in Python, it's
just a standard library
call to UUID4, so pretty
straightforward.
And we now want to call execute
so that request
actually gets sent off.
So I now have an active
subscription.
Let's talk about what happens
during the sync.
So I receive that initial sync
back saying, hey, YouTube API
tells App Engine immediately
after the subscription, this
is your chance to get state
about the current collection.
So that's great.
My App Engine app is going to
call playlistItems.list.
In this example, there wasn't
any items in the playlist, so
it's not super useful.
But you can subscribe to
an existing playlist.
So you might imagine maybe
there's five videos already in
the playlist.
Do you want to know about those
five videos ahead of
time in your application, and
that's going to help you later
on when your processing the
exists notifications.
So we call playlistItems.list.
And what I'm going to do is just
make use of the memcache
instance within App Engine and
store the list of current
videos there.
I'm going to be using the
channel ID as a key.
So this just lets me know what
the base starting state is.
And now let's talk about what
happens during exists.
So, again, YouTube API is
contacting my App Engine.
It's hitting a URL that I've
defined during in the
registration.
And it says that this
is an exists.
So, again, I'm going to call
playlistItems.list.
In this particular case, I'm
going to make two different
types of memcache calls.
I want to first retrieve the
previous state of the
playlist, because I'm going to
be using that to calculate the
delta and figure out
what's changed.
I also want to save the new
state within memcache, just so
the next notification I get, I
could go based on this state.
So two different things
going on.
And we'll cover that soon.
And assuming something is new in
the playlist, assuming the
delta didn't turn up empty, I'm
going to use the channel
API to push down notification
to Chrome.
And then I end up using an
iframe embed within Chrome to
play back that video.
So let's take a little bit of a
dive into the code for that.
I'm getting the playlist
ID from that
X-Goog-Channel-Token header.
So I know which playlist I'm
talking about when I get an
incoming notification.
And I'm just creating this empty
set of initial videos.
So I want to populate that with
information about the
current state of the playlist
by making a
youtube.playlistItems.list
call, part of the Python
client library.
And I'm going to say part
snippet and get
some general metadata.
And the most I could get at
one time is 50 videos.
So maxResults equals 50.
But we do have some ways of
working around the fact that
there might be more than 50
videos in the playlist.
And that's by looping through
the request and using the nice
native methods in the Python
client library for paging
through a set of results.
So I'm going to end up going
through a loop while the
request is something
that's true.
I'm going to make the request.
I'm going to take a look at
each item in the request.
I'm going to grab the video
ID, put it in my set.
And then I'm going to call
list_next, which is the way of
handling paging in the Python
client library.
So this will keep going
until we run out of
items in the video.
And now that I've retrieved
the current state of the
playlist, I want to get the
channel ID, which I'm going to
use for my memcache lookups.
I get that from their
request header.
And I'm going to take two
different actions, depending
upon whether this is a
sync or whether this
as an exists action.
So if it happens to be a sync,
what I'm going to be doing is
just storing the current state
of the playlist in memcache
using the channel
ID as the key.
And if it's an exists,
I want to do
something slightly different.
I'm going to look up the
previous states.
I'm going to then set
the current state.
And I'm going to make use of
Python's nice set operations
to calculate what's new
in the current that
wasn't in the previous.
Assuming something is new, I'm
going to basically make the
appropriate Python App Engine
calls to use the channel API
and tell Chrome, hey,
something changed.
So that's a walk through of
how that works, and hand
things over to Yaniv
to talk about how a
client library is used.
YANIV INBAR: Great, Jeff.
That's a really great example
of using the Python client
library in action.
And I just wanted to let you
know I'm actually the leader
of a team of engineers that
develops open source client
libraries to make accessing
Google APIs easy.
And that was a demonstration of
the Python client library.
We actually also have Java and
Objective-C supported--
Java including Android.
And if you've seen the previous
session here in this
room on best practices for
accessing YouTube on mobile
devices, you've seen the Java
and Objective-C client
libraries in action.
We actually have a variety of
open source client libraries
as well that are in beta that
we're developing for .NET, for
JavaScript, for PHP.
And just to make sure we try to
capture as many languages
on as many platforms as
possible, we actually have, in
early stages of alpha
development, libraries in Go,
Dart, Node.js, Ruby, and
Google Web Toolkit.
So I'd encourage you, if you're
going to build this in
practice, to use our client
libraries, and that will
automatically let you use
the best practices.
So, we're going to move
on to questions now.
Thank you very much
for attending.
If you have questions, please
go up to microphones.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, I'll warn
folks, we have really bad
push and polling jokes that
we're going to start talking
about if people don't
ask questions.
So please come up and
spare everybody.
So go right ahead.
YANIV INBAR: Actually, if
you're interested in the
slides, by the way, there's
a link there where they're
actually publicly viewable.
And, as well as you want to
follow us on Google+ where you
can get more information and
followups, such as the sample
that Jeff built.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
Go right ahead.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
with Machinima.
We're a multi-channel network.
Can I get a push notification
anytime somebody who's an
affiliate uploads a video or
changes content on their page?
On their channel, sorry.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
So right now what we have built
in time for Google I/O
is push notification support
for playlist items.
Definitely, video uploads, which
would be like taking a
look at playlist items for a
specific ID, like the uploads
list, that is something that's
very much on the radar.
We want to support that, too.
AUDIENCE: When a video's
uploaded, it doesn't go into
any default playlist, right?
It's just uploaded.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, so we
kind of treat it as if it were
uploaded to playlist
with a special ID.
It's going to be supported
shortly.
AUDIENCE: What I mean, it's
not known ahead of time.
There's no default playlist,
quote, unquote.
JEFFREY POSNICK: It's a little
strange, but we do treat it as
if it were uploaded
to a playlist that
has a special ID.
So it will be possible to follow
the same method to
subscribe to new uploads.
AUDIENCE: No, I mean, is
that a known ID, when
you say it's a default?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so that every
channel out there has that
default ID.
So like default ID 0 is the ID
where things are uploaded.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, it's
like channel.contentd
etails.relatedpl
aylists.uploads.
AUDIENCE: So right now, so what
you just said would work
for tracking new
video uploads.
JEFFREY POSNICK: This will
work shortly for that
scenario, yes.
Not as of right now, but yes.
It will soon.
And that's a perfect use case.
We want people to be
able to do that.
AUDIENCE: Right.
OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
That's actually really handy.
Thanks.
What I want to know is, when
you send back the exists
response or the exists post
request, do you have plans to
put in the delta or the current
state of what you have
rather than me going back out to
get something from the API?
JEFFREY POSNICK: So it varies
from API to API.
Yaniv, you know a little bit
more about what cloud storage
is doing right now.
AUDIENCE: Like if I define
the resource
type of what I'm tracking?
YANIV INBAR: To repeat the
question, it's a great
question, do we have plans to
add more information when you
do receive an exists
notification about exactly
what has changed the delta.
It's actually a great
question.
So the Google Cloud Storage
API actually
does implement this.
The JSON content includes a URL
where you can literally
receive a feed of what
has changed for your
notification channel.
JEFFREY POSNICK: So for YouTube
APIs, I think what
we're demonstrating today is
not really going to be the
final version.
I can't promise that there is
going to be adjacent payload
with the delta.
It's an obvious case that
it would be useful.
We'll see what ends up
being implemented.
YANIV INBAR: We appreciate
the feedback.
And we'll take that in to
future development.
We really think of this
as the start.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
So just to get a little bit
of clarification on
the guy from Machinima.
So you can subscribe to events
from other people that aren't
necessarily owned by
your entity, right?
So I could subscribe
to your channel?
OK.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
You can.
AUDIENCE: So is there a limit
on how many things I can
subscribe to?
And is there going to be
any sort of API quota
stuff around that?
JEFFREY POSNICK: I'm
sure there will be.
There are quotas associated
with making
that initial watch.
I mean, if you compare the quota
consumed by making a
watch or refreshing a watch
every hour, because it does
expire after an hour, versus
polling every minute, you're
going to come out ahead
by doing this.
So just to clarify that larger
question, so it does ask me
for OAuth 2 credentials before I
could create a subscription.
But I do not necessarily
need to subscribe to
something that I own.
So the OAuth 2 credentials
identify me, but I might want
to subscribe to the uploads
for Google Developers or
playlists like Google Developer
Zone or any other
channel that's out there.
That is possible.
That's supported.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
YANIV INBAR: There's actually
one important point that we
didn't have time to go into,
which is if you're watching
for changes in a playlist that's
public, that's not
actually only accessible by
single user, you don't
necessarily need to ask for
consent from the user.
But the way that you do
that is a bit complex.
But we'll be able to follow up
with you later if you're
interested in that.
AUDIENCE: And just to clarify,
this isn't for comments or any
other data aside from
video playlists?
JEFFREY POSNICK: So this is
built on top of the YouTube
Data API version 3, what we're
talking about with YouTube.
Obviously, there are other
APIs out there.
So what's fair game to
eventually support this is
anything that the YouTube
Data API V3 supports.
We can't commit right now
to every single type of
collection will support it, but
things like the uploads
playlist, that's obvious.
I'm really hoping that we'll
soon have support for the
activities, or if you're
subscriptions, when a new
video is uploaded into a channel
you're subscribed to,
that sort of thing.
Right now, there isn't actually
support for comments
in version 3 of the data API,
so we can't really offer any
push notifications there.
AUDIENCE: And what's the
timeline on what we just saw
today versus what's going to
come down in the future?
JEFFREY POSNICK: I don't have
a specific timeline.
Yeah.
It should be fairly soon.
We scrambled a little bit to
get some working demos for
Google I/O, and we're
really close.
There are a couple remaining
engineering things that need
to be taken care of.
So, we'll post on our Plus
YouTube Dev Google+ page when
things are available, and
we'll make it known.
We'll push things out to you.
You do not need to poll us.
Basically, don't poll us.
Don't email us every day.
We'll let you know.
YANIV INBAR: In terms of
timeline, I just wanted to
make one other note, which is
the Google Cloud Storage APIs
all have released availability
for push
notifications with their API.
And the other point is I
mentioned registering the
domain where you receive
notification endpoints, that
hasn't launched yet,
but will very soon.
And we wanted to tell you about
it because it'll become
a requirement.
So you're not surprised by
that when it comes up.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
This isn't necessarily
directed towards push
notifications, but are you guys
planning to add comment
functionality to the
V3 API for YouTube?
JEFFREY POSNICK: There's not
really anything about that
that I can announce right now.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: So I think I have
a little bit of a silly
question, but you said this
current push notification
system is built on the
YouTube Data API.
Is there any chance that it'll
eventually be supported in the
YouTube Analytics API?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Hopefuly.
AUDIENCE: Like changes in
uploads or number of views, et
cetera and so forth?
JEFFREY POSNICK: So off camera,
we have Christoph, who
is the lead engineer for
the Analytics API.
I don't know.
Christoph, what do you say?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yes, poll
Christoph every few hours
asking him when it's ready.
But the more serious response
to that is that the YouTube
Analytics API is built on top
of this common Google API
infrastructure, things
like cloud storage.
So they all use the same
client libraries.
This push notification support
was added on the Google API
infrastructure layer, so
theoretically, as more and
more APIs support it, you'll
be able to get this benefit
from all sorts of different
services.
YANIV INBAR: I love
the question.
I'm happy to hear enthusiasm
about adding more
functionality that uses the
push qualifications.
AUDIENCE: Similar idea, but with
live events, especially
like the start of a live event,
would be great to get
notifications.
I don't know if you can
tell us anything.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I'm sorry--
oh, for live events?
Yeah, that's, again, falls into
the same bucket of things
that theoretically
should be done.
So it's just a question of
making sure the right folks
can prioritize that
highly enough.
So, y Yeah.
Looks like we're done
with live questions.
We're about out of time.
So thanks so much, everybody.
YANIV INBAR: And please rate
our session, especially
if you liked it.
There's a code over there
you can use, or
on your mobile device.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Even if you
didn't like it, we appreciate
all your feedback.
YANIV INBAR: We want your
feedback, absolutely.
If you didn't like
it, let us know.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yes.
Thanks, everybody.